[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL KINLAN: Hi, guys.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
And I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
And today we're doing the GDL
Presents, Google Developers
Live Presents, about the Chrome
Web Lab experiment.
I think it's the first of our
current set of Hangouts that
we're going to run.
And with me I've got
Roger and Matias?
MATIAS: Yep, that's correct.
PAUL KINLAN: Matias,
brilliant.
I got them with me.
And they worked on
the project.
So if you want to give
yourselves a little bit of an
introduction, and--
ROGER: Yeah, I'm Roger.
I'm a creative technologist
at [INAUDIBLE].
And I've been the technical
leader of the project.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
MATIAS: Yeah, I'm Matias.
And I'm a creative technologist
as well, and also
at [INAUDIBLE].
And I mainly focused on the
Orchestra in the Web Lab.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh cool, so what's
your day-to-day like at
the moment, your kind
of average day?
ROGER: I was managing other
developers and doing some
programming as well, as well
as setting a little bit the
rules in terms of programming.
PAUL KINLAN: The technical
direction and everything.
ROGER: Yeah, a little bit.
And handling a lot the client
requests as well, making sure
that you guys were happy
with everything.
PAUL KINLAN: Sweet,
I'm always happy.
So thanks.
[LAUGHTER]
ROGER: And that's it actually.
MATIAS: And I was more into
the code, writing both the
front end and the back end.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, sweet.
MATIAS: For the Orchestra
and interfacing with the
instruments.
PAUL KINLAN: Sweet, so we'll
just do a little bit of a
brief introduction about
Web Lab itself.
So Web Lab is a series of five
real world Chrome experiments
that live on the web and also in
the British Science Museum.
And I don't know how long
it's been-- it's been in
development for quite a long
time now, hasn't it?
But essentially you can go to
the British Science Museum
today and start experimenting
with the experiments in the
real world.
And today we're going to
talk mainly about the--
I'd say the virtual world, but
the online web experience.
So you could be--
the way I always liked to pitch
this was you could be
actually in the museum
interacting with the
experiment through the browser
right there, walk 10 feet
away, still be interacting with
it, walk into the next
room, and still interact with
it in the same way that you
would if you were
at the museum.
And then you go all the way over
to Google I/O last year.
And then you're 7,000 miles
away in San Francisco.
And you're still interacting
with the experiments in the
same type of way.
I think that's a fair
assumption.
MATIAS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's
a fair summary.
So we're going to go through the
actual experiments today.
We're going to go through
one which is
called the Lab Tag Explorer.
And the lab tag itself is kind
of-- it's the core component
of Web Lab, isn't it really?
So if you want to give a little
bit of background on
what Web Lab-- or not Web Lab,
but the lab tag means to you.
ROGER: Yeah, so in Web Lab we
wanted to represent people,
people that is interacting
with it at all time.
And a lab tag is your
identification in Web Lab.
So it's something kind of like
an avatar where you can store
all the content that you're
generating in Web Lab.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool, and if you
look at the screen right now,
we have these two streams.
Are these real-time streams
or are these random?
ROGER: Yeah, they are
generated by code.
And one stream represents
the online people.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
ROGER: And the other one the
people that is interacting in
the museum.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, and these
are all lab tags that are
streaming across?
ROGER: It's not real data
in this stream.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, OK.
ROGER: Once we go into the Lab
Tag Explorer is where we get
the real data.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, should
we have a quick look in?
We'll zoom in.
That's pretty nice.
And how was that built?
Is this WebGL?
ROGER: Yeah, it is WebGL.
It is in three.js.
PAUL KINLAN: And now this is
my lab tag that's getting
built right now.
Can you explain a little bit
what these three symbols mean?
ROGER: Yeah, so each of the lab
tags is generated by one
main shape and two
more shapes.
And there's a variation on
rotation between the shape's
color and size.
And under these barrier
[? rows, ?]
we can acquire millions of
different combinations.
PAUL KINLAN: Millions?
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Wow, that's cool.
ROGER: So it does a lot.
But it's unique for it too.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, and you also
get the lab tags online.
But you can get it in the
real world as well.
ROGER: Yeah, the similar thing
in the museum is that you get
a badge, which you have
your lab tag [? in. ?]
And you can put it into each of
the experiments and collect
all your data.
PAUL KINLAN: Right.
ROGER: And once you go back
home, then you can use your
webcam to scan this badge and
receive all the contents that
you have generated.
PAUL KINLAN: I just want to
cover how do you interact with
the webcam?
Is that Flash or is
it getUserMedia?
ROGER: Yeah, that specific
bit of code was Flash.
PAUL KINLAN: Was Flash.
Is it Flash still?
ROGER: It was this morning.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, cool.
ROGER: There are other things
in Web Lab that have been
using [INAUDIBLE].
That's the specific one.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I think
this has been a really
interesting experiment, really
where we've been trying to
push the boundaries
of what's been
possible inside the browser.
And there are some limits
that we've come up to.
And I think in a later Hangout
that we're going to run where
we talk about the Sketchbots,
we use getUserMedia.
I think, to actually take a
picture of the person from the
webcam using JavaScript.
Where in this case, we probably
used Flash, right?
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I think
this is basically--
there are some things right on
the web that we can't just do
purely nakedly inside the
browser right now.
And we have to do a fallback.
But the theme, it's a
relatively seamless
experience, right?
MATIAS: Yeah, and as you
mentioned before, it's been in
production for a long time.
So when we started with it, we
couldn't use getUserMedia.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I actually
remember talking to you guys
and saying, you know,
getUserMedia is going to be in
the browser in two
months' time.
And then in two months' time,
yeah, it's going to be in the
browser again in two
months' time.
So the really cool thing at
least about Chrome and I
believe Firefox as well
now and Opera, we have
getUserMedia, which allows
us to get the user media.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: That's really
bad, isn't it?
And they allow us to basically
get access to the webcam data
just by JavaScript.
We're not going to
see that today.
We're going to go straight into
the Lab Tag Explorer.
You know, I actually really like
this whole fun screen.
It's [? beautiful. ?]
Sorry, I'm just going completely
off track.
That's fine.
Cool, so the Lab Tag Explorer,
let's jump
into the Lab Tag Explorer.
So we were saying before-- oh,
this is beautiful, very nice
loading screens.
So what's happening in the
background at the moment?
Is this--
ROGER: So this just loading
all the specific bits for
these experiments.
PAUL KINLAN: So do you kind of
cache everything locally in
the user's machine?
ROGER: Ah, no.
PAUL KINLAN: Or is it just
basically saying, we're
loading everything.
When it's unload or
[? DOM ?] content
ready, essentially we--
ROGER: Yeah, this has
everything, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That actually
looks really nice.
You'd normally see
a big white page.
So that's kind of interesting.
That's one of the things I've
been trying to work with
developers on is provide these
relatively seamless
experiences.
Don't let the user see that
things are loading
incrementally in
the background.
Sometimes with documents
it's fine.
But I think for applications
and those types of
experiences, it breaks
away from it.
So should we just describe
what's happening on the
screen right now?
ROGER: Yeah, so these
experiments is all about
exploring the content that all
the users have been using.
So as I mentioned, each of these
little things is a lab
tag, which represents a user.
PAUL KINLAN: Ah, I see, cool.
ROGER: In this view, we can
see the people who are
actually interacting with
Web Lab in this
precise moment of time.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
ROGER: You can see that there's
two streams, one for
the museum people and another
one for the people who are
interacting online.
PAUL KINLAN: So the really cool
thing, and I'd encourage
anyone who can get to the
British Science Museum in
London, is that when you go into
the museum, you see these
lab tags falling from the
ceiling right down to the
floor, don't you?
It's really nice.
ROGER: You have the same
experience that we've been
seeing in the online.
There it's represented
in a very big screen.
PAUL KINLAN: So I saw some kind
of lines come up before
when I clicked on someone
from the US.
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: There we go.
ROGER: They're showing some
connections between them.
PAUL KINLAN: Nice.
ROGER: Some people probably
they are having lunch.
Or people who are interacting
with Orchestra, some different
data, data visualization
of the users.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
really cool.
And these are actually
live users now?
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: People who are
going or recently interacted
with a Sketchbot.
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That's pretty
cool, isn't it?
MATIAS: And also, these items
flying by, it's--
we choose half an hour
ago all that has
interacted since that part.
So it's constantly updating.
And you can sit for hours
and just look
what people are doing.
PAUL KINLAN: This is really
cool, isn't it?
So just to talk about some of
the technology about this,
this is based on the user's
rough location.
Is this using App Engine's
request notification or the
requests country location
information?
Or is there some
other type of--
ROGER: No, well, [INAUDIBLE].
But I think they finally used
some kind of custom built
system to get the information.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so it just
basically finds the country
and then maps it on.
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty nice.
So the client side technology
in this, this is
all WebGL as well?
ROGER: This is WebGL.
This is using three.js,
the same.
And we've been trying to--
for the movement of them,
for the animation--
we've been using steering
behaviors.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
ROGER: And as you can see,
there's some behaviors for
them to feel a little
bit alive.
But at the same time, they
all follow this path.
PAUL KINLAN: I kind of like how
they've just tried to get
themselves around where
my mouse was.
ROGER: Yeah, we're
in level one.
So this is a nice interesting
bit which in 3D, it's quite
tricky to go from the 2D
world to the 3D world.
For example, the mouse
is in the 2D world.
And then you next interact with
some objects that live in
this 3D world.
But three.js makes
it very easy to.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, so is that
one of the reasons why you
chose three.js in
this project?
ROGER: Yeah, basically without
three.js and with the time
that we've had, it would
have been impossible.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, does Mr.
[? Dupe ?] know that we--
ROGER: Yeah, we've
been talking.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, he's
cool, isn't he?
That's cool.
That's really interesting.
So these are kind of like
voids essentially?
ROGER: Yeah, they are.
Each of them is like a void.
PAUL KINLAN: And did you notice
any performance issues?
I mean, you're streaming quite
a lot of data across the
screen at the moment.
Were there any performance
issues when you
were building this?
ROGER: Yeah, there
was actually.
So these are all sprites,
each of the lab tags.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
ROGER: But if you use
one texture--
you see that animation?
PAUL KINLAN: Mhmm.
ROGER: So how this animation
is done is using a
spreadsheet.
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
ROGER: And if we were using just
one spreadsheet per each
particle, it was impossible
to create this
with so many particles.
So what we ended up using,
it's a system where we
generate textures as
big as they can.
Taking in browsers, I think it's
a canvas of 2,048 pixels.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
ROGER: And then we fit in as
many lab tags as we can, as
many lab tag sprites per
each of the lab tags.
And then we have some kind of
easy system with some indexes
to access them.
So we're using one or two
very big textures.
And we use UV mapping and
UV offset to access
each of the lab tags.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
So I've actually just clicked
on one of the lab tags.
And we've got this little screen
up here, which is the
lab report.
Can you explain a little bit
about the lab report?
I think you might have
done it at the start.
ROGER: Yeah, so the lab report
is what records all your
interactions.
So you can find all your content
that you've been
generating in Web Lab
in the lab report.
PAUL KINLAN: That's pretty
cool, isn't it?
MATIAS: And some things need
video to render recordings
from the museum, if you draw
yourself in the sand with a
sand robot for our Sketchbots.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
MATIAS: And the Orchestra
records you and gives you back
a video as well.
So they may take
time to render.
So you will see a progress here
and can come back at any
point and view your
recordings.
PAUL KINLAN: That's pretty
cool, isn't it?
That's very nice.
That's one of the things I
really liked about the whole
Web Lab experience.
I took my kids there.
Well, one is only two.
And he couldn't do anything.
But Jack is six going
on seven now.
And he absolutely
loved the place.
He had his little lab tag.
He checked into every
single thing.
We got back home, put the lab
tag in front of the screen.
And we could share it today.
But I haven't got a lab tag from
my experience when I was
at the museum itself.
But yeah, we got it all back up
on the screen pretty much
straight away.
It was a beautiful experience
really.
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
So we have this other section.
Sorry, I just want to jump
in the other location.
Here we go.
That's beautiful that.
MATIAS: And here we're loading
a lot of data, for many days
back in time.
PAUL KINLAN: Right, OK.
MATIAS: And generating
spreadsheets for this as well.
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So this is probably
a silly question.
How is the data stored
in the back end?
Is it all in App Engine?
Or is it in MySQL databases?
ROGER: It's in App Engine.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, OK, cool.
So you record everything that
happens into App Engine and
then haul it back.
When you bring it back,
is it JSON?
ROGER: Yeah, it really
is JSON.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
ROGER: And it's amazing
how all the [? VI ?]
JavaScript in [? time ?]
is working.
And it's so fast, so, so fast.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so how many
data points would you normally
bring back do you
think in that?
Because it took about five
seconds to bring everything
back, is it?
ROGER: Yeah, it depends a little
in the graphic and
everything.
But I don't have any numbers
where it's thousands of them.
And in each of them, there's
lots of information.
PAUL KINLAN: So you're
saying it goes back
over a couple of days.
So we can, in theory jump
back over time.
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So can you explain
a little bit how you
actually built this little
time sequence thing?
Is it just a series of planes
that you put into a 3D space?
Or is it--
ROGER: Yeah, it's basically,
everything is contained in a
3D container.
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
ROGER: So we don't
move the camera.
We just move this container
up and down.
And it creates this effect
of going back in time.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so you
just move the camera?
ROGER: No, so the camera--
PAUL KINLAN: It's fixed.
ROGER: It's not moving.
And then we have a 3D container
that just moves.
PAUL KINLAN: I got you.
That's pretty cool.
So if I look at it in this
projection, is it everything
prior to this time?
Or is it just at this
point in time?
ROGER: So this is at
this point of time.
And then if you scroll to the
left, it goes back in time.
And you can see that it goes.
PAUL KINLAN: And this is all
data that we've pulled, that's
been pulled back?
ROGER: Yeah, and when you're
scrolling, we're actually
simplifying it a little
bit because there
were too many points.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
ROGER: And it was becoming--
PAUL KINLAN: So it looked
like coalescent
points in the beginning.
ROGER: Yeah, so there's less
points when you scroll and
then when you release
all of them.
PAUL KINLAN: Excellent.
Yeah, that's so cool.
[INAUDIBLE].
Cool.
ROGER: It's very interesting
to see the different flows.
PAUL KINLAN: This is, yeah.
ROGER: Different days
and locations.
PAUL KINLAN: All right.
I'm just going to play with this
for a little bit longer.
Man, that's insane.
That's a lot of interaction,
isn't it?
Cool, so I think we're
close to the end.
I mean, is there anything else
you want to say about this
experiment, like technical
challenges that
you might have faced?
MATIAS: Yeah, the performance.
We tried to run their
location [? U ?]
and had debugged data
from the start.
And it was a set number
of points.
And it went fine all the time.
And then we started trying it.
And it crashed directly because
we were filling it up
too fast, too fast
with points.
But yeah, smart solutions
and limiting the data.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so all the
coalescence and everything.
MATIAS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
Well, it's beautiful guys.
Congratulations.
[LAUGHTER]